on sunday after washington quarterback
dwayne haskins had four turnovers ron
rivera said he's not ready to pull the
plug on the second year first round
draft pick monday
ron rivera was saying something
different here he is
there is i mean again and and and you
brought up the point and it's a very
good point is that there are guys in
that locker room that are playing well
enough for us to win and again we have
to make sure everybody is playing well
enough to win at that point and there is
there there is there is a a cut-off
point for me there is
okay we don't know what the cutoff point
is it's not four turnovers but it tells
you at some point that there will be a
removal of dwayne haskins if this
continues and it shows you how quickly
things can change week one he was the
star he was the hero he was the guy who
delivered the stirring halftime speech
when ron rivera was getting an iv that
was planned as part of his cancer
treatment and it was all hey dwayne
haskins showing leadership and all the
offseason stories about dwayne haskins
in great shape and he does look
different yes he's not playing any
different that's the problem his numbers
are down you know completion percentage
yards per attempt passer rating all down
so far this year compared to last year
chris yeah it just it doesn't have a
great look you know third moments where
you sit there and you go wow that was a
nice throw no doubt about it but there's
too many throws that are errant and just
all over the place there's too many
decisions that are shaky and then of
course the offense has not been anything
special yeah the week one comeback
there's no doubt great leadership there
he made a few plays but still that was
struggles though the eagles handed them
that game and handed that offense a few
touchdowns to basically say hey you guys
are struggling here you go we want to
get you going i mean that's what the
eagles and carson ones do right now for
teams but
then week two arizona not much better
didn't make any bad mistakes but i'm
sure with ron rivera who's a defensive
coach he looks at last week on monday's
film and goes wait those three
interceptions you threw events against
the cleveland browns they were bad and
they were in parts of the game where you
know it's 24-20 it's 10-7 one time
they're on fringe field goal range a bad
decision bad throw down the middle of
the field the other two interceptions
later in the game they were just really
bad reads so it's going to make a
question a coach question mike they're
going to go
is he seeing the field the right way
that's that's going to be it's in those
type of interceptions where they go he's
not comfortable there's no way he should
have thrown that he's not seeing things
the right way and i think that's what's
a little alarming right now at least to
me
and here's what's unfortunate he didn't
play a lot of quarterback at college
yeah he started for one year and some
guys just take a little bit longer but
the problem is with so many of these
quarterbacks who come in and play right
away and play well right away that
raises the bar for the guys who may need
a little more time that's one of the
saddest parts of football today you
don't get the same opportunity the
quarterbacks used to to figure it out
and i've said this time and again for
the last 20 years if that standard
applied to terry bradshaw he'd have been
back in shreveport pumping gas long
before he threw the immaculate reception
long before he led the steelers to a
super bowl win he would have been gone
because it used to be five years to
figure it out now it's five weeks yeah
to figure it out or they're going to
start thinking about their rights but
you're right joe burrow justin herbert i
mean all these guys are showing up yeah
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports